down you're right I always had uh thanks
for traveling I like traveling I like
going places seeing things
and uh
Great Outdoors when I was a kid I used
to love to uh go hunting fishing and
stuff uh growing up with a lot of real
father figure where'd you grow up in
Glendale and then here in West L.A but
you were born in Miami yeah I was born
in Miami
what was your family like growing up uh
my father was a great father he he was a
drug dealer I didn't know this uh he was
a drug dealer uh
sort of a not a tough guy he was just
always an argument with my mom but he
was a good good father he gave me
everything I wanted he had uh on Miami
River he had a business which still runs
now but it's not it's not uh his
business anymore or the family business
it's we still hold the name uh on the
river uh Garcia and harada and uh
during the 70s
nobody he ran a lot of drugs up and down
and my mother was scared and she was
always left alone
people with guns while I was showing up
in their house and she just didn't like
it and uh
she was the one I she was the one that
always started the fight uh but my
father was he he did hit her but it
wasn't bad you just hold her down
because he was gonna do she was small
she's small but she always did the
hating and uh my father was always like
trying to hold her down and she didn't
have bruised up and he never called the
cops but a she would steals his money I
remember that and she stole a bunch of
money and came over here with me and my
sister had a younger sister a couple
years younger and then I and uh she just
passed away a month ago and I'm drinking
and uh she was murdered also okay how
would you describe your childhood uh my
childhood growing up in in in Glendale
was great uh wanted to be a voice a Cub
Scout I became a Cub Scout my mom worked
hard at IBM she didn't know no English
but uh uh her visa at that time uh in in
the 70s a recent attempt I guess gave
her the job in Florida and IBM was was
in Glendale and she worked IBM and she
worked hard to give us everything make
it happy we didn't have a father figure
in our life at first but we we met uh
she met somebody in email had a Mexican
guy named Alejandro and uh
he was cool at first and everything and
uh but things
turned out I mean
it's like [ __ ] my head but my mother
didn't know what was going on for a
while it's just I was sad I was flunking
it all all grades and and everything I I
started flunking and not only that I was
uh
I wouldn't talk I wouldn't talk I lost
interest in a lot of things and uh
he's just uh he he's ruined it it ruined
me completely what age was this uh that
was seven years old
at seven after preschool uh this was
your mom's yeah my mom's boyfriend I
don't know uh they had a a child
together my younger brother and uh I
don't know if you'll probably see
yourself he'll hate me later but
uh he did he a lot of people don't know
what really happened uh
but he here uh I'm sorry
my mother Mary Alejandro and he was a
cool guy long hair uh sort of like a
hippie type but but more of the Macho
and he used to beat us beat my mom and
and he was always like uh wanted to
dress real dressed to impress and my mom
I just liked the guy I mean he worked
hard he did have he put uh food on the
table gave us all the presents we wanted
give us money but I mean it was for
something at first we didn't know I
didn't know it was going off to my
sister also but uh
he would tell me hey I'll give you five
dollars but you got to do this I was
gonna I didn't know
what was going on I mean he had to grab
his balls or and stuff like that and uh
he he was a lot of other things it was
uh
I remember a teacher asking me one time
if uh something was wrong because I
acted different her name was Miss Pena
and uh she named the child after me uh
she asked me if I was eating the paint
off the walls because I was acting real
weird he drugged us he drugged me and I
think it was roofies I don't know what
kind of drug he gave us uh
but it it affected both of us real bad
uh
my speech patterns started changing uh
it was just crazy I remember waking up
one time and climbing the wall trying to
see myself climbing the wall thinking I
was a spider and my mom would be yelling
at me and uh you know but I would wake
up at in in the morning we'd come last
you know I mean I didn't know it was
that though I mean it was slippery slimy
and I thought it was normal I thought it
was normal and and my mom
she would see that and and would take us
to the doctor I think the doctor told
her something but she would refuse it
like like
to to accept it or or something I I I
barely asked her uh
why I mean and she just didn't know and
she honestly she didn't know she became
an alcoholic from that she started
drinking and uh and we started drinking
I guess I I drank at a young age also at
first and then my sister started
drinking also and that's where she
passed away from last month and uh
drinking and taking pills
and uh
I I started
messing up
trying to turn I hated myself I wanted
to be something else I didn't want to be
William I wanted to be something or get
away from everybody and get away from
her mother get away from
the little boring what I thought was
pouring and and crazy life I had so I
started turning to other guys that that
I looked up to and their younger
brothers and stuff and hanging out with
them and uh
I have
I turned into a gang member I mean at
first it it didn't seem like so but I
wasn't paying attention to my mother I
remember age 11 i i i i aged 11 and 12 I
told my mother that I was gonna buy my
own clothes and uh
said okay I mean but uh yeah I just
wanted to address differently I wanted
to be something else I would lie about
everything I would uh uh tell people
that were rich or got people we had
money and just
can make a whole different identity
and uh I just didn't like me anymore I
uh
I had no interest in school I remember I
was young five to six I wanted to be a
school boy I wanted to be things I
wanted to be the cop I wanted to be a
fireman a a Cub Scout I did come with a
Cub Scout I had I was losing interest
in a lot of things I love fishing I
loved hunting I loved the outdoors I
still do and
um
right and it stuck with me that stuck
with me but I I didn't want a father I
wanted a brother and the older brother I
wanted to learn things
yet I there was nobody teaching me
anything and
you don't see any taught me was
sex was this guy that went until I was
nine years old
and uh I guess my mother figured it out
and uh
she moved us here to West L.A and uh to
get away from him by that time we we had
a younger brother named Alex also and uh
he
I guess wanted to follow my mother more
he apologized but it wasn't just only uh
him Alejandro it was his brother Gustavo
every time he came from Mexico same
thing
and and to please him I I remember I was
I mean I was bringing able and sexual
abuse came yeah
your mom's boyfriend and his brother and
his brother and his brother and so I I I
I didn't know what was going on so I
touched his balls I mean I
and I thought it was everybody did that
and uh I remember going to school I
would touch the girls to the girls with
asses and stuff and and uh
I tell the kids hey you want to touch my
balls that's from Miss pineal my teacher
uh it was a second grade she she uh she
said hey what are you doing you don't do
that what's going on in your house and
uh she goes that's not right
she called a cop and the cop didn't like
what was going on at all and he talked
his Spirit but he couldn't do nothing
about it
they couldn't do anything about it and
my mom got excited she got mad that I I
mean that I told the story and
um that's when espanol was telling me
that's not right and uh but life should
be this way that way I started hanging
around a kid named Brian and he was good
he was a great kid and he was telling me
that
stuff that I was doing shouldn't be
happening and his father started telling
me that I mean he beat up Alejandro
and I remember I felt real bad about it
but I've seen channel was happy
and uh no one got into an argument with
me
and they both beat me
and uh I felt like like [ __ ] I mean
what's right what's wrong
and uh I started being a loner I started
hanging out by myself sort of an outcast
and uh
our stealing
I was stealing uh the things because my
mom would no longer buy me the things
that I needed or wanted I wanted to be
Little League
uh first at uh
what's it called TiVo
and uh she didn't buy anything
um the things I wanted or I have to
refuse I stole the stuff I stole the the
balls and love and everything went to a
specific Park in Glendale and to the
parking and enrolled in yeah I made the
team and I had my mom signed me on
uh she didn't pay uh she didn't pay for
the
for my uh my fee but somebody else did
and uh other dads would take me out and
uh I think they they knew what was going
on
uh and they would try to like give me
advice
and uh
I just hated myself for that I mean that
I couldn't do nothing about it that I
couldn't change anything
and later I found out that it was
happening my sister
is one day uh we're living in Colorado
and uh
I understand it's my sister
what's it called to go get something
from the market we're little kids
markets around the corner though and uh
my sister's looking at me like oh no he
sends me to go to the market and I
didn't want to I didn't want it my
sister said no no no don't go don't go I
said why everyone go get candy and gave
us five dollars you could no no don't go
please don't go and so I stayed and he
got mad
and uh he took the five dollars back and
then I said I asked my sister what's
going on and he wasn't judges me I'm
like what and uh last when I first got
the idea it was happening to her too and
I asked her questions like where does he
touch you down here and I touched her
too you know at first I touched it
you're like you're you're what he feels
because I just don't like it it hurts
and uh yeah he touches me too she she
started hugging me and I hugged her back
and we went and told our mother together
and my mother still like At first like
you shouldn't be lying you shouldn't be
saying [ __ ] like this and and uh
we kept quiet about it and uh Gustavo
would come and same thing my sister and
me who drug us both
and uh we wake up with [ __ ] in her ass
like that and but we thought it was
normal
well like I said my mother
got in practice away when I was nine my
sister was
and she was six
uh at five or six and I was you know she
was seven actually she was seven that
was nine and uh
right here to West L.A we live not so
far from the Staple Center and uh mother
made another boyfriend here
and a Cuban guy and he
he was a pretty mother was pregnant at
that time and and uh Cuba guy was real
cool people
and uh I still I would still want her
there's still a
careful weary of adults and yet when if
if the guy was just a little older than
me I'd take him on as a big brother
follow him around but out here with
Mexicans and and uh the gang banging
style I mean it was just new to us and
uh
I just wanted to be like them they had
girls that had money that cars they had
everything I wanted and uh
and forget about school forget about
listening to adults and forget father
figures forget all this
I mean and my sister the same thing uh
she followed along she followed me along
with me uh
we uh I became a gang member first and
then uh
I've never told anybody the story after
that uh I just tried to hide it stash it
away and so did my sister and uh but it
was freaky things going on it was we are
I guess that was my my sexual life was
changed completely I knew what sex was I
I wanted to practice sex I wanted to to
uh what's it called explore but not with
boys but women and I wanted to explore
it I was watching porn and looking at
porn and uh
at the same time when I see these guys
with women it's like you were doing
anything here but yeah my first real
sexual experience was when I was 12. and
uh it was a lady named Blanca my mom's
friend and she's she was like 25 I was
12 years old and she was drunk at the
house my mom was an alcoholic full-blong
at this time and uh
I would see I was normal for me to
already see my mother drunk we lived in
smaller smaller apartments and
I I would see her drunk and we still me
and my sister would steal the people's
money
and uh but blocked out
come here and uh and my sister would
laugh at me hear me that was me under
the covers with Blanca touching her and
she taught me where to touch her and
stuff
and uh
she said that she's told me one time it
wasn't right what happened to me and I
would try to block that out and uh but I
I at the same time she said those people
should be killed and that it was right
she introduced me to a guy named Manuel
manual and Billy Manuel and Billy were
friends they worked in a place here in
downtown called New York hardware store
place was open since 1910 and uh it was
like my second job my first Christmas
MacArthur Park running out the boats and
giving out snow cones second job uh was
right here right there in New York
hardware store and uh manual ability
became sort of like my big brothers and
they were great these guys would teach
me from fishing everything I wanted I
had lost interest in they picked up and
uh they moved me into her house I'm
telling you I I moved away from my
mother at a young age uh
went to live with them in East L.A
manual uh manuals like
treating me like a a little brother and
since I was already interested in sex at
a young age he would show me like hey
this is what you do to a girl this is
what you do a girl and uh I never told
him what went on but he kind of like
figured out or or had
that like uh I think uh Blanca told him
that something was wrong like like
with our childhood and uh he took me in
had me working John Durant was the owner
at that time the old man had been
through World War one and World War II
and the Korean War so this guy is like
everything I wanted to be is all the
things he had done uh uh uh he had
trophies of fishing all the places I
wanted to go he he had gone I loved
hearing stories and and uh John would
tell me all kinds of stories and and he
would he hired me at a young age he said
this was only supposed to be a summer
job but I worked there for good school
and uh and I would hang around with
friends at night time but I had money
now and oh oh we fixed the guns there
they fixed guns and I I started learning
how to Tinker with guns at a younger age
and uh
I would just to to prove these other
guys being gangs gangs and stuff they
were from 18th Street uh
around my house they were from 18th
Street and I would uh
show off like take a gun and show them
that I knew how to fix it and someone
would bring guns to me and say hey can
you have this I try I would take it
manually fix it I'll take it back to
them so I started getting a little
popularity like that and uh
Fidel was a great guy
he was a drug addict I didn't know this
is before crack came out he was cocaine
at it and my mom I guess that was her
first time being she she never did any
dope she tried it I went to the hospital
because of it uh
uh Fidel was a cool person
and uh where the Staple Center stands
out now and it's like a block away uh we
lived there and uh Georgia and uh
Fidel was a cool person he uh
I don't know if my mother told him uh
what was going on but one day Alex came
came to see his son he was really born
and beat up beat him up
and he that was a he's been in prison in
Cuba and everything and he didn't go for
none of that [ __ ] yeah I remember him
saying yo you like touching little kids
such a man
and touch a man grab my nuts yeah he's
trying he's trying to grab my notes and
I liked
the fear that he put in you know I like
the fear he put it on I I I just enjoyed
it and and allowed to see all Alejandro
was begging to see his son
my little brother Alex and uh if your
dad was just laughing you got a knife in
his hand oh slash your face I'll cut
your nuts up you mean once you touch me
and uh I just like and uh
508 no man's ever supposed to touch you
you touch women you don't ever let a man
touch you I mean and if he does cut and
he cut him where he split his throat
shoot him do whatever but don't ever let
him not touch and I like that I mean I
like that it gave me a sense of you know
what and he had a gun he would let me
hold his gun and uh he would let him
take out you know you would get [ __ ]
up and I would just take the gun so I'd
show off of it and but then I knew how
to handle a gun it's manual Billy
a game of time where I started hearing
well I I started knowing what sex was
and and
what are to do's and not to use I mean I
I I did not like gay people at first I
did not it was like and I hated people
to touch kids and uh every time somebody
said oh yeah he's a child let's do it
I've I'd be the first one to raise my
hand as a kid raise my hand to you shoot
them beat them up do I was always
beating them at first and uh well Fidel
said always stuck in my head and uh you
kill him
you kill him I mean those guys deserve
to be dead and uh it's stuck in my head
I remember just one day that they were
both coming over they told my mother
they were coming well that Gustavo was
coming from Mexico
and uh they would like my little brother
to show up at the house and uh if me and
my sister didn't go too and my mother
said no no I said I'll go I mean I'll go
I'll go I'll go because he was offering
me money
and uh I went they didn't touch me he
didn't do anything they just said hi
how's your mom doing are you taking care
of your little brother and I believe I
am and but I was quiet and I just wanted
I had seen movies and I had at what my
friends told me my new friends told me
what to do to a guy to uh
look at their behavior but not Behavior
parents but
look at where they live and stuff like
that and I had a gun I had a little 25.
and uh in my head I was what they did to
me was like a No-No I I really wanted I
wanted them dead and uh what it is my
sister I just kept quiet and one day I
caught the bus went all the way to
Glendale I knew where he worked and and
I shot him
I shot him and he worked in a Brick Lane
Factory by the river and uh the Valley
River and uh not Brooklyn it was a
ceramic uh they made ceramic uh statues
and stuff and I went in there I just
shot him yeah I shot him in the neck and
uh at first I was scared uh but I did it
just like I did a little birds and
little uh
a chipmunks and stuff and I had a little
chipmunk rifle but uh with a 25 never
shot anything uh it was just targets but
I shot him in the neck and uh
I didn't say anything I just shot him
and uh I hated him he just kept saying
no no no no no no
he's gonna beat me up he's gonna what we
need I just kept you hey unloaded the
clip I I I just your whole I was 12
years old 12 and a half and uh I didn't
say nothing I didn't tell anybody
anything what do I have I felt very
happy next was his brother uh his
brother came for his funeral
and uh to to take him to Mexico and I
remember so nobody knew that you did it
no no he just had somebody uh went over
there tried to take his money and then
they came up with all kinds I stole this
chain
and uh I had his I was wearing his
chains
quite a while his big old Waterloo
Regional Guadalupe it was a 18 karat
gold chain and I had it stolen from me
yeah right here in downtown oh that was
a young kid and I pulled that 25 out but
he misfired or didn't fire it all the
guy and my buddy Eddie I told me he told
me hey ma'am the hell man you wouldn't
shoot that guy go again I told him
that I shot this guy and I told her I
didn't tell him why I just told my
instructor
and then he goes yeah I'll leave you
with me I did shot him in there and uh
it was he deserved it I very much
deserved it I told him to touch my
sister made around online
yeah he deserved it I mean and then uh
when Gustavo came to to take Miss
brother's body back to Mexico
and his mother wanted to back over there
like that uh I had the opportunity
because Gustavo wanted to go visit my
little brother and this is my mother was
quiet and everything and but Gustavo
died
behind the house I didn't shoot him I
had my friends
42nd little criminals Club
and uh we went over we jumped the [ __ ]
out of them beat the shots of Granada he
had and and just beat him up beat the
shadow he was practically knocked out
when I grabbed this little piece of wire
like a bicycle wire and
Joe and uh my buddy hadn't seen that one
he goes hey can I kill him so [ __ ] him I
mean yeah she said [ __ ] him
I wanted to be tough guy but then I
wanted to be uh
not recognized but just play tough I
wanted to be something else than what I
really was I was just scared all along
and uh I choked him he was half asleep
and we were knocked out when I did when
he did and uh he died too and uh
uh I cried I I I didn't let nobody see
it or anything I just took off running
and uh I wanted to tell my mom I wanted
to tell a couple people I didn't tell
anybody and uh put my buddy Eddie I had
to go tell his mom his mom really could
tell
a cop and
I got busted it was about
I think three weeks later
I ended up confessing to a crime and
they took me to juvenile hall to both
crimes yeah for both crimes because I
wanted to play tough guy I didn't know
how to answer the questions it was right
here at the station and uh
uh the cop was asking me a bunch of
questions why I would tell them because
I wanted to and I just want to be tough
guy and look down if I told Morgan I was
from and uh
he put me in for the first degree murder
and uh I didn't know what was going on
he said the cop said he was gonna let me
go if I told him the whole story but I
didn't tell him that I got my list
and uh as I said if I can why did you do
it it's because I wanted to I mean it's
because I feel like man you spoons your
whole life you know that I didn't D
those words didn't penetrate my mind
it's just I wanted to I wanted
well
I was confessing someone like like
sayings slipping up so much even to my
lawyer that the judge
the the arraigned me at first were you
in juvenile hall the judge the judge you
get at first is the judge sticks with
you the whole case and he
he talked to me like like he was my
lawyer he if it benefits you he'll
accept a plea or he'll he'll I mean he
just wants to know why and uh
he he he said you think you're a bad I
remember you said you think you're a bad
guy you think you're a tough guy you
think you're a younger I said I am and
uh he got me he broke me down
and so many words he he kept asking me
questions and taking information out of
me until I told him little by little
what happened and he cut everything
right there he called somebody else I
remember he had called somebody else
because I want you to write this down or
jot this down and uh I knew it he kept
saying I knew it I knew it I mean I knew
it I knew it why and he made me confess
that was the first person I ever
confessed to what really happened and uh
like the whole thing and uh and he shook
my like like hit me in the head Patty me
hugged me and he goes I would have did
the same thing don't ever say that I
would do the same thing and he goes but
you don't kill I mean you just don't
kill in this country you don't kill and
uh you're gonna be over it you said
you're gonna be okay this is after eight
months going to court and stuff and uh
they're gonna send me to ya and stuff he
ended up sending me to camp
and uh how things went in Camp or
determined if I was going to go to y a
till I was 25 or not uh things went
Green
Camp I was happy uh whatever happened
being in Camp was like for me wasn't a
train gun it was like going back to
school uh what happened
uh in the past was like
forgotten and I was in the outdoors I
was in La Verne Laverne uh California
San Dimas but Vernon area I've seen it
here and everything and and there was uh
things conservical Durant I still
remember the 80s of these guys were so
cool they would show us what the
outdoors was how to start a fires like
being Cub Scouts all over all over again
and uh
it it I wanted to be there I wanted to
be participate I wanted uh they didn't
have no counseling or anything like that
but the judge always wrote me and uh he
ended up dying but he always brought me
uh sent money for I can have things and
and uh
he he was a great guy I mean uh how much
time did you get uh I a year and a half
it wasn't for two murders what
determined if by I uh uh what's it
called I I wasn't even in high school
yet but it how I behaved to learn a word
pattern I remember oh my God
it was like I learned how to weld I
learned how to write and handwriting I I
uh
it was like the best thing that happened
to me you can't and uh
he when I got back out uh gang bang was
in style
and it was good and bad
manual was still around that time he
hadn't passed away yet but Manuel and
Billy were still around he still wanted
me to work but I had lost interest in
that I was more into the gang bang at
first I was wanted fishing the hunting
but I was more into the women now at 14
15 uh hormones were raging and I went to
a women and one woman and since I had
that face that everybody could trust I
think okay uh
I was called upon for everything and I
had no problem with it so where's your
life gone since then excuse me where's
your life gone since then he's gone down
the hill
it was good at first I was rising up in
the gang uh Argan we started Our Gang uh
it was a club that threw a football club
at first and then it became a gang
because somebody got killed and it
became a gang and then since I had that
reputation already I had gone to jail uh
I know how to fix guns uh older gangs
would send their guns to us or I would
fix it or whatever and I knew a lot of
backgrounds and I was that was my only
interest is was gone to end women and uh
I did not use drugs until I was what 22
and uh it was the worst thing I ever did
try drugs while I was niod when I was in
prison uh but I was trusted for a long
time
and uh
I liked it because everybody treated
with me respect uh
everybody wanted to be hanging around
with me and doing a home and and you're
in the hall the second time I went to
Camp everybody wanted to hear because I
had been the murderer already and uh
something
popular happened at that time
um it was a shootout happened where the
convention Center's at and it came out
on video and it was me shooting at the
people you could pull it out of YouTube
it was me and a friend shooting at a car
and we shot I shot the guy in the butt
and he actually he's actually my friend
now
I shot the guy in the butt it was a gang
called Burlington and uh arrival and uh
it became popular he still not had a
little reputation and then the the 90s
hit it was even worse it was it was I
was I went to prison uh for guns and uh
my reputation was growing and it's like
there was a stories out there that I did
this I did that and I didn't but I yeah
yeah just stay quiet yeah so since you
were a teenager just in and out of
prison yeah yeah or selling drugs
I did not touch marijuana I did drink I
do not touch marijuana I didn't touch
anything I well I did try mushrooms I
did try acid I did not like I did try
these I do not like any what is your
drug today uh today's heroin it was
heroin now it's fentanyl where do you
stay now uh I still while I was with my
wife she kicked me out now I'm with my
mom
and my mom kicked me out also I go back
in my year every day she started singing
I lost so much weight I had an accident
a few months months back and uh it went
to fentanyl because it was hard to get
heroin after my Suboxone started getting
losing it being high I used to I started
abusing my Suboxone and being high I
would lose it and uh I started on 15 I
started oding I've never OD'd so much in
my life and uh my life now is like uh
I'm a three Striker I've been to prison
what three four times already I've even
been a federal prison uh for extortion
and guns
nah I Dibbles and dabbles almost every
type of crime decision uh sex crimes I
hate sex crimes people with sex crimes
and and to this day uh
I I just regret how my life has turned
out completely I have my partners a
total opposite from me we've been
together for a long time she came to
this country not knowing her word of
English and she's a microbiologist now
like she's my total opposite yes
uh we're not married but we're even Vice
partner we've been together forever and
uh uh one daughter and and uh honestly
he's not my daughter well and she she
messed up while I was locked up and had
a baby girl I I mean I was there too
I'll try to be there and uh but I I she
didn't know I use drugs
until like 10 years ago
and uh I told her she found out what
heroin was how bad it was and at first
she thought the world was over well now
she thinks the same thing about Fentanyl
and we're arguing about that now and
she's trying to she's trying to stay
strong but and she's trying to be
supportive
yeah but I'm messing it up child abuse
is kind of why you your life took this
path yeah I told her finally told her
what happened in my life and uh not
everything uh
I I I recently told her again
that I I took Alejandro out and uh I
haven't told my little brother
he doesn't know he keeps asking about
his dad
and uh
I don't know if he's gonna talk to me
but I did tell him when I was drunk one
time that I took them out
yeah but he said you take everybody out
you can't remember that my brothers
turned into a responsible person uh he
went through Foster Homes at first and
then to to camps and now he's a success
story and uh I admire him now and
and uh I look up to him and he he looks
down on me I think he does
and uh
he uh and now my sister passed away last
month and from from alcohol
it's
it's hard man it's hard let's hit up a
key like this is so
he's taking his instance here when you
take everything from him and uh
it's hard to live life be trying to be
something else you're not
and I don't know if uh 50 years old now
ah
my sister's dead but it's uh I feel like
she's still an alcoholic
yeah I should we try to talk like adults
now
uh
I
nobody hardly knows the story but if you
do if there's anybody out there
been hurt or anything like this talk
about it I think it gets better over
time you start learning how to love
yourself after a while you come to terms
with who you are
and uh how to treat yourself
I mean I'm messed up but now I'm using
pets at all right now I'm stuck on it
now
uh I'm running for my parole
and uh
I might turn myself in just to help and
hopefully my wife will be happy if I do
I just want something normal
I'm tired of living a life of trying to
be something else and having something
else
or have having things I just want normal
simplicity
and
that's all all right William thank you
so much for sharing your story thank you
good luck with everything
I felt good